movement 19 is still infecting people a  reminder here as we talk about the  coronavirus flu season is coming around  once again a new survey from the  national foundation for infectious  diseases found 44 percent of americans  are either unsure about getting a flu  shot or already aren't planning to get  it at all  health experts say though the flu shot  is safe they say it is effective and  they suggest you get it before halloween  you can get the flu shot and the  coronavirus vaccine and the hpv vaccine  at a free health clinic happening this  weekend it's over at the east las vegas  community center starts tomorrow at nine  of course all the vaccine clinics across  southern nevada rna newsnow dot com